المشهد اللي همم الحالي هو يعني لا يعبر
عن ازمه اللي همم تنظيم الاخوان همم بقدر
ما هو يعبر عن ازمه المجموعه مهيمنه
ومسيطره همم وتتنافس على المصالح همم
الجماعه نفسها ليس عندها مشروع حقيقي
مشروع الاخوان ومشروع هيمنه يعني انت اذا
بتسال عضو الاخوان ماذا تريد هدفه الاسم
همم الاعلى النهائي كما يقولون اقامه ما
يسمى بالدوله الاسلاميه واهدافه المرحليه
الفرد المسلم ثم البيت المسلم ثم الاسره
المسلمه ثم المجتمع المسلم هكذا يدعو ان
سالت 10 من الاخوان ما شكل هذه الدوله
ستجد 10 هذا معلوم استاذ هيثم معلوم عيوب
عيوب الفكره الاخوان والاولاد
نعم نعم الحديث عن الاعلام فقط
نعم نعم هذا بيبي ينعكس على الحاله التي
بها الجماعه يعني الان هذه الجماعه على
ماذا تتنافس حتى على ماذا تختلف حتى لا
يختلفون على كيفيه اداره المشهد في في مصر
اداره الخلافات مع الانظمه السياسيه في
المنطقه المشهد الحالي مشهد شخص
مجموعتين
نفسه على المصالح على النفوس على الاموال
على المنابر الاعلاميه باعتبارها قد تكون
مصدرا للاموال على همم